s'agissant du deuxième tour s'agissant
du deuxième tour je crois qu'il faut tu
encore attendre un peu je remettrai au
parlement au plus tard le 23 mai comme
la loi l'imposé le rapport qui
déterminera s'il peut avoir lieu en jeu
dans le cas contraire nous devrions
décider collectivement d'une part de
sadate et d'autre part des modalités de
son report qui emporterait avec lui un
certain nombre de conséquences qu aucun
d'entre vous dans cette enceinte
n'ignore le gouvernement et moi-même
consultons consulteront très
régulièrement les associations d'élus
les groupes parlementaires pour préparer
cette échéance